this is dj shortcut and you're watching
levels levels levels of turntablism
today i've been challenged to explain
turntablism in 15 levels of increasing
complexity
a lot of stuff that turntablism
encompasses coming from the foundation
of dj turntablism is the art of using
the turntable as a musical instrument to
produce entirely new musical
compositions the two most known sounds
that we use in scratching is fresh
and awe
freshened all comes from a song called
change the beat by by freddy the sounds
fresh and awe are pretty sharp and
pretty clear from the minute you release
the record
just on the release alone you know how
sharp it comes in this is level one the
baby scratch
this scratch was invented by grand
wizard theodore from new york there's
two types of baby scratches a short one
otherwise known as tip i look at the
platter as a clock i have a line on my
record the mark will show us where each
sound is position wise it would be from
12 o'clock to 1 o'clock
and a long baby scratch which would be
from 12 o'clock to 2 o'clock
i'm applying enough pressure on the
record where i can still see the slip
mat right under the record still rotate
for the baby scratch my fader stays open
and my hand stays on the platter with a
baby scratch you want to make sure that
you get a little bit of the air right
before the sound starts so you can hear
the sound in full
now let's do a combination of both baby
scratches with a beat
[Music]
one of the things to keep in mind is
there's four beats to a bar one two
three four
two
three four counting bars help us keep
time to when we scratch to these beats
whether you tap your foot nod your head
move side to side sway back and forth
that's how you keep time counting bars
for level two we're increasing
complexity by manipulating the amount of
pressure on the platter while using the
crossfader level 2 push release and
drags
a push scratch creates a higher tone
a drag scratch produces a lower tone
and a release scratch produces a
mid-tone
to do these scratches we start with the
fader closed with level one we use the
light amount of pressure on the platter
with the push my hand position is at
nine o'clock and i'm pushing the record
board applying a good amount of pressure
onto the platter to produce a higher
pitch
for the drag scratch we add pressure to
the platter to create a breaking sound
i'm moving the crossfader from the
closed position to the open position and
i'm moving the record from 12 o'clock to
about 2 o'clock
a release scratch requires you to
release the record right when the sound
starts to play at its normal speed while
moving the crossfader to the open
position
and this is what it sounds like with a
beat
[Music]
the most common mistakes when we do
these scratches is your hand placement
on the record you want to make sure your
hand is in the nine o'clock position
that way you have enough space between
nine o'clock so about 12 and then back
to six o'clock where you don't end up
knocking the needle off the record for
the next level we're going to increase
complexity by adding speed and sharper
cuts this is level three the stab
scratch
this scratch starts with a fader in the
closed position kind of similar to the
push scratch my hands on the nine
o'clock position and i'm moving forward
while moving the crossfader into the
open position
right away i'm pulling back the fader to
the closed position while moving the
record back to the original position
the difference between the push scratch
and the status scratch is i'm adding a
little bit of speed while using the
crossfader
my hand never leaves the record as i'm
pushing the record forward i'm moving my
crossfader to the open position at the
same time
but right away i'm pulling the record
back and the crossfader back to the
closed position without hearing the
reverse sound
and this is what it sounds like with a
beat
[Music]
a common mistake is not moving fast
enough and hearing the reverse sound
right there i'm hearing the reverse
sound which you're not supposed to do in
a sab scratch in this next level we're
about to increase complexity with our
crossfader this is level 4 the trip
scratch
this scratch was made popular by dj
jazzy jeff in the song the magnificent
jazzy job so my fader starts in the open
position as i'm moving the record
forward i'm moving the crossfader back
to the closed position the crossfader
functions like an on and off switch the
coordination between the fader and the
record is important to practice in order
to catch the beginning or the tip of the
sound reducing the chirp
the second part of the scratch is moving
the crossfader back to the open position
while moving the record back to the top
of the sound
now this is what it sounds like with a
beat
[Music]
the most important thing to remember
about the scratch is real coordination
between the record and the fader for the
next level we're about to increase
complexity with our timing and hand
control this is level five tears
similar to the baby scratch your hand
never leaves the platter for the tear
but what's different with the tear
scratch is adding an additional push
which sounds like a split or tear in the
sound the most common tear scratch is
the motion of moving the record forward
and moving the record back twice my hand
positions at nine o'clock markers at 12
o'clock and my cross fader is open
wow
the most common mistake when doing the
chair scratch is not accentuating each
movement on the platter
this is what the tear scratch sounds
like with a beat
[Music]
in the next level we're about to
increase complexity with speed and
rhythm this is level 6 the transform
scratch
that name would come from the sound the
robots would make from the early 80s
cartoon the transformers this scratch
has been associated with dj cash money
and jazzy jeff so what we're doing here
is using the crossfader as an on and off
switch while moving the record back and
forth my hand positions at nine o'clock
and i'm moving the record back and forth
pretty much a baby scratch while moving
the crossfader off and on we'll do this
with two clicks
now to get a circular motion in that
sound we'll move the record back and
forth clicking the crossfader twice in
both directions
now you can add more clicks to this
scratch to get different patterns
for the transform scratch if you use
longer sounds you'll be able to add more
clicks within that sound
this ah sound starts from 12 o'clock to
about five o'clock
i'll add as much clicks as i can within
that moving the record back and forth
this is what the transform scratch
sounds like with the beat
[Music]
so with this scratch the principal
rhythm maker comes from your movement on
the crossfader level 7 fades
the fade scratch is a combination of
either doing tears or babies on the
platter while moving the volume control
from 10 to 1 giving it that loud to soft
effect
the speed can change depending on what
tempo you're scratching to this is what
the fade scratch sounds like with a beat
[Music]
in the next level we're going to do a
combination of all the techniques we've
learned so far level 8 a combination of
levels one through seven over a beat
[Music]
bye
[Music]
one of the most common mistakes when you
do combos of all those scratches is not
being able to pace yourself in the next
level of increasing complexity we're
about to take on one of the most
difficult scratches involving the
crossfader level 9 the crab scratch
the origins of the crab scratch came
from the uk by a dj named dj xl who
named it the twiddle he was using both
of his fingers on the crossfader while
using his thumb as resistance to create
off and on sounds kubrick came up with
the idea to utilize all his fingers from
his pinky to his index finger to skate
across the in and out position as your
thumb acts like a spring to close the
fader back my hands on the nine o'clock
position i have my sound starting at 12
o'clock the platter movement is
basically a baby scratch so basically
i'm rolling and clicking my fingers from
pinky to index finger as my thumb works
as a spring to move the fader back to
the open position
this is what the crab scratch sounds
with a beat
[Music]
the most common mistake when you do a
crab scratch is not sounding fluid with
it you try to get every click in there
some people actually use their ring
finger to their index finger while doing
the crab scratch i like using all four
fingers from pinky to index to get that
full effect and to get all those clicks
in there this is what it sounds like
from your ring finger to your index
finger
but when you add your pinky in there you
get a lot more clicks in
there in the next level we're about to
increase complexity with our fader
control level 10 the one click flare
so we start with an open fader after
doing a trip forward immediately reopen
the fader
the second half of the scratch is
rewinding the record back to the top of
the sound which faders open and do a
reverse chirp and immediately open the
fader
this is how we do the one click flare
with a beat
[Music]
so the one click flare is definitely a
hard scratch to get right away it's
going to take a lot of practice because
you have to be in sync with the fader
and the platter movement to get that one
click to make two sounds we're about to
increase complexity by adding more
clicks to the one click flare this is
level 11 the two click flare otherwise
known as the orbit scratch
the orbit scratch or the two click flare
was created by a dj named dj disc from
the visible scratch pickles just like
the one click flare we added one click
and made two sounds now we're adding two
clicks to create three sounds you're
starting your crossfader in the open
position as you move your platter
forward you're clicking the crossfader
twice but ending again in the open
position
now to complete the scratch we're going
to do the same motions back and forth
two clicks forward two clicks backwards
but ending the crossfader in the middle
position
this is what the two click flare sounds
like over a beat
[Music]
one of the most common mistakes when you
do a two click flare is it kind of might
sound like a transform as it comes out
first it's one of those scratches where
you have to find your sweet spot you'll
know you'll have the two clip flare when
you hear kind of a rolling circular
motion that's why it's called an orbit
where it's just kind of traveling when i
do the two click flare i kind of do a
galloping motion on the crossfader
and you'll find that roll somewhere as
you move the record back and forth
for the next level we're about to
increase complexity by layering multiple
scratch techniques level 12 the rhythm
scratch
the rhythm scratch was a popular scratch
done in the 80s by tj's like jazzy jeff
magic mike dj aladdin the rhythm scratch
is made of five baby scratches two
normal babies
one short baby
another normal baby
and one short one
when you put all those together it
sounds like this
with this scratch we don't use the
crossfader it solely relies on your hand
motion on the platter
for this demonstration i'll be using the
pitch control to move the beat from a
slow bpm to a faster one
for the next level we're increasing
complexity by making a beat off one
turntable level 13 drum scratching
[Music]
one of the first times i heard drum
scratching was jam master jay on a run
dmc record called here we go live at the
fun house in the beginning of that
record jab master j would grab a kick
and a snare off one record and make a
drum beat
i have my kick at 12 o'clock in my snare
at about 2 o'clock we have to be very
accurate while doing drum scratches
because if you get it in the middle of
sound it'll sound kind of sloppy and
muddy you want to get even a little bit
of that air before the sound starts to
get crispy or going back and forth from
sound to sound and holding those sounds
and isolating them as we go
[Music]
when you do the drum scratch you
definitely have to have some kind of
internal metronome in you swaying back
and forth tapping your foot you don't
really see any live trimmers just kind
of stiff and just doing that right
they're still kind of grooving same
thing applies when we do the drum
scratch
[Music]
knowing the position where you are on
the record using the clock system
knowing where your marks are at is key
to the scratch
[Music]
so while doing the drum scratch i wasn't
using the crossfader i was using the
volume control to be able to go back and
forth from kick to snare that's just my
preference or you could use the
crossbreeder
in this level we're about to increase
complexity with one of the most advanced
art forms in turntablism level 14 be
juggling
one of the first times i heard bee
juggling was from a dj named steve d
from new york from the executioner's
originally known as the x-men basically
he was creating a new pattern from
existing records and doing live manual
remixing back and forth from turntable
to turntable normally done with two of
the same copies of records for this
demonstration on my left turntable i'll
have a kick
and on my right turn table i'll have a
snare
i'll basically make a pattern and
creating a complete bar going back and
forth from kick to snare think of beat
juggling as a cut and pace method you're
continuing the beat pattern from where
you left off on one trim table by moving
the crossfader to the other turntable in
order to resume the sequence doing this
you'll have to have a good amount of
cadence rhythm and have that internal
metronome like we did with drum
scratching basically it's drumming but
with two turntables it's also important
not to hear any residual sound from the
turntable that you just moved the
crossfader from so that you complete a
clean transition from one platter to the
other
[Music]
for this final level of increasing
complexity we're about to do everything
that we learned right now all in one
this is level 15 a combination of all
levels
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so with everything we learned today like
i said it takes a lot of practice a lot
of patience and a lot of focus i hope
watching this video inspires you you'll
never know what you'll find out messing
with two turntables either whether you
scratch or make me draw the routines up
stay true to what you're doing stay true
to the craft once you find something out
there maybe no one knows share that with
people because that's what makes this
art form evolve and grow